think of all the time that's wasted in
your organization how do i get
inspiration how do you identify an
orphan problem how do we get going when
i'm stuck
i'm huggie rah i'm bob sutton and we are
fixers
brought to you by stanford online
we're going to have a series of
conversations
with people who are smart entertaining
and good at fixing problems in
organizations we have them in different
industries regulated versus unregulated
because fixing isn't the same everywhere
a very reasonable question for all of
you to ask is why do i need to listen to
these conversations how is that actually
going to help me first of all anybody
can play a constructive role in fixing
you're going to learn what fixers do
people who know how to make the right
things easy
wrong things hard and do it without
driving other people crazy what
questions might we ask guests to get our
conversation going how do you spot
which is worth battling and which you
can't fix for now how do you distinguish
between snafu and fubar
when can you fix it and when is it time
just to exit scene right
how do you decide who do you want to
help and how and why certainly we're
going to ask them some of their favorite
messes that they've cleaned up and some
[ __ ] they've created that other people
had to clean up because we all do that
in life you're suggesting a fascinating
hypothesis which is
is actually created at the top and falls
out at the bottom yeah i don't think
that's a new hypothesis
the question is who cleans it up
they're really part of the immune system
for the organization oh i love that so
huggy do you think the stanford
administrators are going to let us use
the term fixers maybe we should just
call it send help in trouble
that's good i like that that's good
because there's an acronym yeah i got
that
no we gotta go and fix some right away
bob that's our job let's go right
[Music]
you